You just don't want someone acting radically around you like and you know that.
So he walked down Bluer.
Okay.
And there's people there that should really be institutionalized,
but we deinstitutionalized them all so they could be free and free to be,
you know,
suffering and malfunctioning out on the street.
That's what the freedom ended up being.
But you know,
when you walk by someone like that who's
moderating away to the voices in his head and you know,
maybe
striking out against whatever it is that's plaguing him and you will make eye
contact.
You might even go across the street,
you're certainly going to give him a wide berth.
You're going to keep a distance between him and you and you're going to hope
that you don't attract his attention because he's not in the dominance hierarchy
and you don't know what the hell he might do.
And that's unexplored territory too.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Like
we inhabit time and space,
not just space and not just time.
We didn't have it time and space and our territory's our spacial temporal.
We're here now and this is safe now and it's safe partly because of the physical
structure and it's working,
but it's also safe because none of you are manifesting peculiar behavior.
But if you started to manifest peculiar behavior,
if you stood up and started muttering or yelling or maybe attacking someone next
to you,
all the rest of you would freeze first because then all of a sudden this would
be unexplored territory.
The match between what you want,
which is a peaceful lecture that you hope has some content.
The match between what you want and what's happening has vanished.
And so then you're not,
you don't know where you are.
And so then what do you do when you don't know where you are?
What do you do when you don't know what to do?
Well,
if your computer,
you just crash,
but you know what good is that to you?
You're just going to die.
That isn't helpful.
Okay?
You freeze first and then maybe you cautiously cautiously attend or maybe you
don't.
Maybe you just keep your damn eyes averted and you sit there and you hope that
no one notices you.
That's a predator.
That's a prey response,
right?
That's like a rabbit frozen when it thinks that Fox is looking at it.
And we were prey animals for a long time.
There was a cat that they recently discovered,
a prehistoric cap that had this bottom single tooth and they found out that it a
human skull fit right inside its mouth.
And so it could grab you here and Pierce the back of your skull with its,
with its single tooth.
And that's what it was evolved for.
So,
you know,
okay,
it's under such conditions.
We evolved and we're predators obviously,
but we're tasty predators.
And so other things were perfectly happy to eat us.
Okay.
And so when you're aware you don't know what to do,
you act like a prey animal and that's probably what you should do because maybe
if you keep your head down and shut the hell up,
there won't be any attention to attracted to you.
And maybe you'll get through it.
You know,
you might decide,
unlikely to intervene and take the guy down,
but,
but you would be the exception rather than the norm.
And it's unsurprising.
Okay.